- Bienvenue dans Comprendre
l'information et le calcul quantiques.
Je m'appelle John Watrous, et je suis
le Directeur Technique d'IBM Quantum Education.
C'est la quatrième leçon de la série et c'est la dernière
leçon de la première unité de la série sur les bases
de l'information quantique.
Jusqu'à présent, nous avons parlé de
la façon dont l'information quantique fonctionne pour les systèmes simples et multiples, nous avons examiné le
modèle de circuit quantique,
et nous avons observé certaines
limitations fondamentales de l'information quantique.
En chemin, nous avons
rencontré des concepts mathématiques importants
notamment les produits tensoriels et les produits scalaires, et nous continuerons
à utiliser ces concepts et nous en introduirons de nouveaux
au fur et à mesure que nous en aurons besoin.
Dans cette leçon, nous nous concentrerons sur trois exemples fondamentaux importants : la téléportation quantique, le codage superdense et le jeu CHSH,
qui est aussi appelé l'inégalité CHSH et n'est pas toujours décrit comme un jeu.
Ce ne sont pas de simples exemples
destinés à illustrer le fonctionnement de l'information quantique, ils constituent vraiment des éléments clés des fondations
de l'information quantique et
ils apparaissent dans des contextes différents et parfois inattendus au sein de l'information
et du calcul quantiques.
L'intrication joue un rôle clé dans ces trois
exemples, et en fait, c'est l'intrication qui les fait fonctionner
et qui les rend intéressants. Ainsi, cette leçon sera, en quelque sorte, notre première occasion de
voir l'intrication en action
et de commencer à explorer ce qui rend l'intrication si intéressante.
Le plan de la
leçon est très simple : nous allons procéder un par un
à travers les trois exemples que je viens de mentionner,
la téléportation quantique,
le codage superdense, et le jeu CHSH.
Nous allons expliquer ce que sont ces choses, ce qui les rend intéressantes et nous allons effectuer des analyses qui expliquent exactement comment elles fonctionnent
à un niveau mathématique.
Avant d'aborder le premier
des trois exemples, qui est la téléportation quantique, il est approprié d'abord
de présenter les personnages,
Alice et Bob, au cas où tu ne
les connais pas encore.
Alice et Bob sont des noms
donnés à des entités ou agents hypothétiques dans des systèmes, des protocoles, des jeux,
et vraiment tout autre type d'interaction que tu pourrais souhaiter considérer impliquant l'échange d'informations.
Ils sont apparus pour la première fois dans le
contexte de la cryptographie dans les années 1970, mais la
convention d'utiliser ces noms de cette façon est devenue très courante
dans un contexte bien plus large depuis lors. L'idée est que ce sont
des noms très courants, du moins dans certaines parties du monde, et ils commencent par les lettres A et B,
et il est aussi pratique
de désigner Alice et Bob par les pronoms elle et lui, juste par souci de concision.
Nous imaginons généralement qu'Alice et Bob se trouvent dans des endroits différents et qu'ils ont des
objectifs et des comportements différents
selon ce dont nous parlons.
Par exemple, si nous parlons
de communication, c'est-à-dire de la transmission d'informations, nous pourrions décider
qu'Alice est l'émettrice
et Bob est le récepteur
de l'information transmise.
Parfois Alice et Bob
coopèrent, c'est très typique, mais parfois ils
rivalisent ou ils peuvent avoir des objectifs différents qui peuvent
ou non être compatibles
les uns avec les autres, mais tout cela
doit être précisé dans la situation donnée.
Bien sûr, ils représentent des abstractions et pas nécessairement de vrais êtres humains.
Nous pouvons aussi introduire
des personnages supplémentaires comme Charlie et
Diane ou différents noms qui représentent différentes
personas comme Eve
pour un espion ou Mallory pour quelqu'un se comportant de façon malveillante,
selon le contexte.
Dans tous les cas, nous verrons Alice et Bob dans les trois
exemples que nous allons discuter dans cette leçon et de temps en temps
tout au long du reste de la série. Je vais aussi faire quelques
remarques sur l'intrication avant de passer aux trois exemples.
Dans la leçon deux, nous avons rencontré cet exemple d'un état intriqué de deux qubits.
C'est l'un des quatre états de Bell, et on pourrait dire que
cet état particulier représente l'exemple archétypal
d'un état quantique intriqué.
Nous avons aussi rencontré cet
exemple d'un état probabiliste de deux bits.
C'est analogue à l'
état intriqué en un certain sens, mais il n'est pas intriqué,
l'intrication est un phénomène uniquement
quantique,
essentiellement par définition.
Il existe une définition mathématique précise de ce qu'est l'intrication et ce que dit essentiellement cette définition, c'est que l'intrication
est une corrélation quantique non classique.
Mais ce n'est pas très
utile au niveau intuitif, c'est une définition de l'intrication en termes de ce que l'intrication n'est pas,
et c'est probablement pour cette
raison qu'il est franchement assez difficile d'expliquer ce qu'est l'intrication et ce qui la rend spéciale
en termes intuitifs.
Quand les gens essaient d'
expliquer ce qu'est l'intrication en termes intuitifs, on
entend souvent des explications qui ne permettent vraiment pas de distinguer ces deux états
de façon significative. Tu peux entendre l'idée
que si tu mesures l'un des deux qubits intriqués,
alors l'état de l'autre
WEBVTT
est en quelque sorte instantanément affecté ou que l'état des deux qubits ne peut pas être décrit séparément
ou que les deux qubits
gardent en quelque sorte une mémoire l'un de l'autre, ou même qu'
ils sont émotionnellement attachés d'une façon ou d'une autre.
Mais pourquoi ces propriétés
ne sont-elles pas vraies pour cet état ?
Ces deux bits sont intimement liés, chacun a une mémoire parfaite
de l'autre au sens littéral, mais
ce n'est pas un état intriqué.
Une façon d'expliquer ce qui
rend l'intrication spéciale et ce qui rend cet état
très différent de celui-ci est d'expliquer ce que
nous pouvons faire avec l'intrication
ou ce que nous pouvons voir se produire
grâce à l'intrication, qui dépasse les décisions que nous prenons sur la façon dont nous représentons notre
connaissance à l'aide de vecteurs.
Les trois exemples
que nous allons discuter dans cette leçon ont cette nature en ce qu'ils illustrent
des choses que nous pouvons faire avec l'intrication que nous
ne pouvons pas faire avec cet état
ou avec n'importe quel état classiquement corrélé.
En effet, il est très typique dans l'étude de l'information et du calcul quantiques de voir l'intrication comme une ressource
grâce à laquelle différentes
tâches peuvent être accomplies.
Et quand nous faisons cela, nous considérons cet état comme représentant
une unité d'intrication.
Nous désignons cette unité d'
intrication par e-bit, le e signifie
intriqué ou intrication.
Il est vrai que ce sont deux qubits, mais en tant que quantité d'
intrication, c'est un e-bit.
Tu peux aussi voir une paire
de bits classiques ordinaires dans l'état probabiliste
corrélé de tout à l'heure comme étant une ressource qui est
un bit de hasard partagé.
Cela peut être très utile en
cryptographie de partager un bit aléatoire avec quelqu'un, à condition
que personne d'autre ne sache ce qu'est ce bit, pour qu'il
puisse être utilisé comme clé privée
ou comme partie d'une clé privée, par exemple, à des fins de chiffrement.
Mais dans cette leçon, notre attention se portera sur cet état intriqué et
sur les choses que nous pouvons faire avec.
Et juste pour clarifier la terminologie, quand nous disons qu'Alice
et Bob partagent un e-bit, ce que nous voulons dire c'est qu'
Alice a un qubit nommé A,
Bob a un qubit nommé B, et ensemble la paire A, B
est dans l'état Phi plus.
Peu importe les noms que
nous choisissons pour les deux qubits, bien sûr, nous pourrions
choisir des noms différents, mais tout au long de cette leçon,
nous garderons ces noms
dans un souci de clarté. Le premier exemple de la leçon
est la téléportation quantique,
que nous désignerons dorénavant
simplement comme téléportation par souci de concision.
La téléportation est un protocole qui permet à un émetteur de
transmettre de l'information quantique à un récepteur en utilisant uniquement l'intrication
et la communication classique pour
accomplir cette transmission.
Cela n'a absolument rien à voir avec l'interprétation habituelle
du mot téléportation dans la science-fiction, qui veut que la matière disparaisse
à un endroit et apparaisse à un autre.
La téléportation quantique est juste un nom censé évoquer cela comme une image ou comme une métaphore pour ainsi dire.
Ce qui est téléporté, c'est
l'information quantique et non la matière, et cela se produit
via une transmission d'informations classiques
combinée à l'intrication.
Pour comprendre exactement
comment fonctionne la téléportation, il est utile de commencer par
planter le décor, pour ainsi dire.
Nous allons imaginer un scénario impliquant Alice et Bob et
ce scénario est le suivant :
Alice a un qubit nommé Q qu'elle
aimerait transmettre à Bob, ce qui signifie qu'elle
veut que Bob tienne dans ses mains
un qubit qui soit exactement
dans le même état que Q lorsqu'ils commencent le protocole.
En d'autres termes, nous parlons du problème fondamental de
la transmission d'information ou de la communication.
Nous avons un émetteur nommé Alice
et un récepteur nommé Bob et Alice veut envoyer
de l'information quantique sous la forme d'un qubit à Bob.
Il y a cependant une contrainte, à savoir qu'Alice n'est pas
en mesure d'envoyer physiquement Q à Bob, tout ce qu'elle peut faire c'est d'envoyer des informations classiques à Bob.
Alice et Bob ont aussi
une ressource supplémentaire, à savoir qu'ils partagent un e-bit.
Voilà donc le scénario, il est
facile d'imaginer des situations où la contrainte qu'
Alice ne peut pas envoyer physiquement Q
à Bob est une abstraction raisonnable.
Si Alice et Bob se trouvaient sur
des continents différents par exemple, ou si Alice ne connaissait pas
l'emplacement exact de Bob, alors envoyer physiquement un qubit
serait probablement assez difficile.
Mais la communication classique
est bien sûr non seulement possible mais aussi très peu coûteuse
dans ces circonstances.
On pourrait maintenant se demander s'il est possible pour Alice et Bob d'accomplir cette tâche sans même avoir besoin du e-bit partagé.
En d'autres termes, existe-t-il
un moyen de transmettre un qubit en utilisant la communication classique
seule ?
La réponse est non, il n'est pas possible de transmettre de l'information quantique en utilisant uniquement la communication classique, et ce n'est pas trop difficile à prouver
en utilisant quelques notions de base de la
théorie de l'information quantique, que nous verrons dans la
troisième unité de la série.
Pour l'instant, une façon intuitive
d'y réfléchir est de penser au théorème de non-clonage.
WEBVTT
Imagine qu'il existait un moyen
d'envoyer de l'information quantique en utilisant uniquement la communication classique,
mais la communication classique
peut facilement être copiée et diffusée, donc cela signifie
que la communication classique
pourrait être diffusée à deux
récepteurs, Bob et Charlie, disons.
S'ils recevaient tous les deux la
même information classique d'Alice, est-ce qu'ils
se retrouveraient tous les deux avec Q ?
Cela suggèrerait que nous avons cloné Q, mais nous savons que c'est impossible.
Juste en passant, observons
qu'il est certainement possible de décrire
des vecteurs d'état quantique en utilisant de l'information classique.
Chaque vecteur d'état quantique
que tu verras dans la série t'est décrit
en utilisant de l'information classique qui a été transmise à quel que
soit l'appareil que tu utilises pour regarder.
En général, on pourrait imaginer
décrire l'état de Q en utilisant des bits classiques
peut-être avec une certaine précision,
mais ce n'est pas de la communication quantique, c'est juste décrire
des états quantiques sous forme de vecteurs, et nous reviendrons à la
distinction entre eux
dans un moment.
Revenons au scénario cependant, et en travaillant sous l'
hypothèse qu'Alice et Bob partagent bien un e-bit, nous allons
voir qu'Alice et Bob
ont tout ce dont ils ont besoin
pour accomplir la tâche, et c'est ce que fait le protocole de
téléportation quantique, en utilisant spécifiquement deux bits
de communication classique.
avant d'entrer dans
ces détails, cependant, permettez-moi de faire quelques remarques rapides juste pour m'assurer que les hypothèses sont claires.
Premièrement, nous supposons
ici que l'état de Q est inconnu d'Alice et de
Bob, donc en particulier,
Alice ne peut pas envoyer à Bob une
description de l'état Q car elle ne le connaît pas en général.
Nous devons aussi tenir compte de la possibilité que Q soit corrélé avec d'autres systèmes, y compris la possibilité
qu'il soit intriqué
avec d'autres systèmes et la
transmission de ce qubit à Bob doit préserver ces corrélations.
Enfin, j'ai mentionné
le théorème de non-clonage quand je parlais de
la tentative de communiquer des qubits de façon classique, mais
il y a une autre connexion ici
avec le théorème de non-clonage, à savoir que si Bob
reçoit la transmission de ce qubit Q d'Alice,
alors elle ne doit plus l'avoir
car Q ne peut pas être cloné, et c'est juste quelque chose à garder à l'esprit
lorsque nous considérons le protocole de téléportation.
Le protocole de téléportation
peut être décrit de façon assez simple et directe avec le diagramme de circuit quantique comme tu peux le voir ici.
Il est légèrement stylisé en
ce qu'il montre la séparation entre la partie d'Alice et la partie de Bob, mais sinon, c'est juste
un diagramme de circuit quantique,
tout ce qui est au-dessus de la ligne pointillée
représente les actions d'Alice et tout ce qui est en dessous
représente les actions de Bob.
Le temps s'écoule de gauche à droite comme toujours, et nous voyons que nous commençons
avec ces deux qubits ici étant dans un état Phi plus,
donc c'est le e-bit
avec lequel Alice et Bob commencent.
Nous pouvons mettre des étiquettes sur les qubits pour indiquer clairement lequel est
lequel, donc c'est le qubit A, et c'est le qubit
B qui forment le e-bit,
et c'est le qubit Q qu'
Alice souhaite transmettre à Bob.
Ici nous supposons que
l'état de ce qubit Q est Psi, mais un peu plus tard nous considérerons la possibilité
que Q soit intriqué
avec un autre système. Et ce que le diagramme affirme parce que nous avons écrit psi ici en bas,
c'est que ce circuit
transmet effectivement l'état psi que nous avions
ici sur la partie d'Alice là en bas sur la partie de Bob,
la seule communication
qui traverse la
ligne entre Alice et Bob sont les deux bits
classiques représentés par ces doubles lignes ici.
Réduisons un peu
ce diagramme pour avoir un peu plus d'espace et examinons le
circuit de plus près.
J'ai déjà décrit
les conditions initiales, mais juste pour récapituler, Alice tient un qubit A
et Bob tient un qubit B,
où A et B ensemble
sont dans un état Phi plus, donc c'est ce que cela signifie de partager un e-bit.
Alice a aussi ce qubit Q qu'elle souhaite transmettre à Bob, et nous considérons le cas où Q est dans un état quantique arbitraire Psi.
Nous ne savons pas comment
Alice et Bob sont entrés en possession de ce e-bit.
Il se peut qu'ils l'
aient eu pendant longtemps, peut-être qu'ils l'ont créé il y a un certain temps lorsqu'ils se trouvaient au même endroit
et qu'ils l'ont gardé
pour cette occasion, mais ces détails ne sont pas pertinents ici.
Les étapes qui viennent ensuite, qui représentent le
protocole de téléportation lui-même sont les suivantes, et juste pour être clair,
ce sont les étapes que
le diagramme décrit et nous allons juste
les écrire en mots pour qu'il soit clair ce que
le diagramme exprime.
Alice effectue d'abord une
opération NOT contrôlée où le qubit Q qu'elle
veut envoyer à Bob est le contrôle et le
qubit A est la cible.
L'étape suivante est qu'elle
effectue une opération Hadamard sur Q, puis elle mesure
les deux qubits qu'elle tient,
A et Q par rapport à
des mesures en base standard et nous désignons par a minuscule le résultat de la mesure du qubit A,
WEBVTT
et nous désignons par b minuscule le résultat de la mesure du qubit Q.
Alice envoie ensuite ces
deux bits classiques à Bob et c'est la seule communication impliquée dans ce protocole et c'est indiqué dans le diagramme
par le fait que ces deux
bits traversent la ligne pointillée entre Alice et Bob,
que tu peux considérer comme représentant quelle que
soit la distance qui les sépare.
Après que Bob reçoit les bits
a et b, il fait deux choses.
Premièrement, si a est égal à un, alors il effectue une opération X
ou en d'autres termes, un gate NOT sur son qubit B,
et sinon si a est égal à zéro, alors il ne fait pas ça.
Et dans le même ordre d'idées,
si b est égal à un, alors Bob effectue une opération Z
ou un Z-gate ou un retournement de phase
aussi sur le qubit b et comme
avant, si b est égal à zéro, alors il ne fait pas ça.
Tout cela est indiqué dans la figure où nous avons ces gates X contrôlés
et Z contrôlés où les contrôles sont
les deux bits classiques.
Tu n'as pas à penser à ces gates comme étant des gates de contrôle
si tu ne le souhaites pas, c'est juste une façon commode
d'exprimer ce que nous voulons
sous la forme d'un diagramme de circuit. L'essentiel est que Bob applique
un X-gate au qubit b si a est égal à un et
qu'il applique ensuite un Z-gate
au qubit b si B est égal à un.
Et par souci de commodité, nous pouvons écrire explicitement
l'opération combinée que Bob effectue sur son qubit b,
selon les bits classiques
qu'Alice envoie.
Voilà donc le protocole de téléportation, c'est assez simple en réalité, le
fait qu'il fonctionne réellement est une autre affaire
et bien que l'analyse
ne soit pas si compliquée,
tu ne dois pas te sentir comme si tu manquais quelque chose si tu ne vois pas immédiatement pourquoi cela fonctionne.
C'est pourquoi nous devons
faire une analyse et c'est ce que nous allons faire ensuite.
Pour analyser le protocole de téléportation, nous allons le parcourir étape par étape pour voir quels sont les états
des trois qubits à différents moments.
Nous allons d'abord considérer
le cas où le qubit du haut est dans l'état AlphaZéro plus bêta un, où alpha et bêta
sont des nombres complexes quelconques
qui font que ce vecteur
est un vecteur unitaire.
C'est le qubit Q qu'
Alice essaie de transmettre, mais nous ne nous soucions pas vraiment de
ce qu'il s'appelle pour le moment.
Un peu plus tard, nous allons
examiner la situation dans laquelle ce qubit est
intriqué avec un autre système, mais c'est un bon point de
départ juste pour garder les choses simples
et pour voir comment l'analyse
fonctionne un peu plus clairement.
Si nous considérons l'état des
trois qubits ensemble ici au départ, nous voyons
que cet état a la forme que tu vois ici.
Les deux premiers qubits sont
dans l'état Phi plus, le troisième qubit est celui du haut
selon la convention
pour l'ordre des qubits que j'ai
décrite dans la leçon précédente, et donc nous prenons le produit tensoriel pour obtenir l'état des
trois qubits ensemble.
Nous pouvons développer cette expression
en substituant d'abord la définition de l'état Phi plus et en calculant ensuite le produit tensoriel
et nous obtenons l'état
que tu vois ici.
Ce n'est pas toujours la meilleure
stratégie d'ailleurs, de développer complètement
un vecteur comme ça, c'est généralement une bonne idée d'attendre jusqu'à
d'avoir une bonne raison de le faire.
Mais ici nous avons une raison, qui est que nous aimerions
calculer l'action de ce gate NOT contrôlé et en écrivant l'état sous cette forme,
nous pouvons très facilement le faire.
Et en particulier, c'est
l'état des trois qubits après l'application du gate NOT contrôlé.
Le troisième qubit est le qubit de contrôle car c'est celui qui est
en haut selon notre convention, et le deuxième qubit,
qui est celui du milieu,
est la cible, donc nous opérons
sur les kets en conséquence, si le troisième bit est un
zéro, rien ne se passe,
et si le troisième bit est un,
alors nous retournons le deuxième bit.
Puis nous effectuons le gate Hadamard
sur le troisième qubit, nous pouvons écrire le vecteur résultant
comme tu peux le voir
ici en substituant les
états plus et moins à l'état zéro et à l'état un.
Et si nous voulons avoir assez d'
espace pour développer celui-ci, nous allons devoir le
réduire un peu et maintenant, en substituant les états
plus et moins
par leurs définitions,
en amenant la racine carrée de deux au dénominateur, nous obtenons l'état que tu vois ici.
Et en développant celui-ci, nous obtenons l'état que tu vois ici.
Voilà donc l'état des trois qubits après qu'Alice a effectué ses deux opérations.
Alice mesure ensuite
et si nous voulons analyser les mesures, ce que nous faisons c'est d'isoler les vecteurs de la base standard
pour les systèmes en cours de mesure
comme nous en avons parlé dans la leçon deux, et si nous faisons cela dans ce cas particulier, voici ce que nous obtenons.
Et si tu regardes cette
expression un moment, elle peut sembler un peu particulière car maintenant il semble que le premier qubit,
qui est le qubit du bas
dépende en quelque sorte d'alpha et de bêta, même si à
ce stade il n'y a pas eu de communication à travers la ligne pointillée,
WEBVTT
mais ce n'est qu'une illusion. N'oublie pas que les scalaires circulent
librement à travers les produits tensoriels, donc il n'y a vraiment aucun sens
dans lequel alpha et bêta
sont associés au premier qubit.
Tout ce que nous avons vraiment fait ici c'est d'utiliser des parenthèses conformément à la
multilinéarité des produits tensoriels.
Quoi qu'il en soit, c'est la forme dont nous avons besoin pour voir ce que fait la mesure, et nous pouvons voir une
chose intéressante tout de suite
et c'est que les probabilités des quatre résultats de mesure possibles sont toujours uniformes.
La probabilité de mesurer chaque
paire de résultats de mesure est un quart, donc, en particulier,
il n'y a aucune dépendance
quelle qu'elle soit en alpha et bêta.
Nous pouvons voir cela dans chaque cas en calculant la norme euclidienne au carré de
n'importe quel vecteur qui est mis en produit tensoriel avec le vecteur de base standard que nous avons isolé,
et dans chaque cas nous avons un quart que nous obtenons en mettant au carré la moitié fois la valeur absolue au carré d'alpha
plus la valeur absolue
au carré de bêta, qui est un, et donc nous obtenons un quart dans chaque cas.
Il est assez important en
fait que les probabilités de ces différents résultats ne dépendent d'aucune façon du qubit qu'Alice
veut transmettre.
Nous ne pourrions pas avoir qu'un état arbitraire entre ici et sort là-bas et pourtant une mesure aurait révélé
des informations sur cet état.
Si tu veux obtenir des informations sur un état quantique arbitraire, tu vas devoir perturber
cet état en général.
Voici un tableau qui décrit non seulement les probabilités
des différents résultats, mais aussi l'état des
trois qubits ensemble
conditionné à chaque résultat de mesure possible.
Nous obtenons cela en normalisant les vecteurs mis en produit tensoriel avec les différents
états de la base standard, mais c'est facile dans ce cas,
nous éliminons simplement le facteur d'un demi pour obtenir un vecteur unitaire.
Ainsi, ce que nous avons immédiatement
après la mesure d'Alice c'est qu'Alice a deux bits aléatoires uniformes et c'est tout.
En particulier, elle n'a plus
l'état original et elle n'a aucune
information à son sujet, elle a juste des bits aléatoires.
L'état de Bob dépend maintenant
d'alpha et de bêta ainsi que des résultats de mesure.
Si nous imaginons momentanément
qu'Alice n'a pas encore envoyé les résultats de mesure
de sorte que Bob ne sache pas quels sont les résultats de mesure,
alors il ne serait pas en mesure
d'obtenir des informations sur alpha et bêta
en mesurant son qubit.
Ces quatre possibilités
que nous avons ici sont suffisamment brouillées pour garantir qu'aucune information
sur alpha et bêta
ne pourrait jamais être obtenue
par une mesure. Cela doit être vrai à un niveau intuitif car sinon nous aurions
une communication plus rapide que la lumière.
Alice ne peut certainement pas
transmettre d'information à Bob sans rien envoyer du tout, mais bien sûr Alice envoie bien les résultats de mesure
à Bob, alors développons le tableau pour voir ce qui se passe quand
Bob effectue ses opérations.
Dans cette colonne ici, nous avons les différentes opérations que Bob effectue effectivement pour chacun des résultats possibles des mesures
comme nous l'avons observé avant,
et si nous y allons un par un et que nous appliquons cette
opération au qubit de Bob, qui est le premier, B,
nous voyons que nous obtenons le même
résultat dans les quatre cas et que ce résultat est l'état original.
Ainsi, l'état original du qubit Q a été téléporté avec succès dans B.
Si Bob veut renommer son qubit et l'appeler Q à ce stade, il est certainement libre de le faire, mais l'essentiel est que maintenant
il détient l'état original
qu'avait Alice et bien sûr, par nécessité, Alice ne l'a plus.
Remarque aussi que le e-bit
a été effectivement consommé par ce processus,
la téléportation a un coût
et le coût est un e-bit et deux bits classiques de communication, et quand le protocole est
terminé, le e-bit a disparu.
Nous avons maintenant établi que
le protocole de téléportation fonctionne correctement sous l'hypothèse que le qubit du haut est dans un état quantique
de la forme alpha fois ket
zéro plus bêta fois ket un.
Mais que se passe-t-il si le
qubit du haut est intriqué avec un autre système tel que
l'un de nos qubits supplémentaires
comme nous l'avons ici à l'écran ? Nous pourrions vouloir utiliser la téléportation
dans de telles circonstances.
Peut-être qu'Alice et Bob ont en fait
l'intention d'effectuer la téléportation 100 fois pour qu'Alice puisse transmettre
un registre quantique de 100 qubits
à Bob, un qubit à la fois.
Ou peut-être que ces
qubits supplémentaires ne sont même pas en possession d'Alice
et que quelqu'un d'autre les possède, peut-être qu'Alice ne sait même pas
qu'ils existent.
La question est : est-ce que
la téléportation fonctionne encore même si le qubit téléporté est intriqué avec un autre système ?
Ici, l'état du qubit Q avec le système
supplémentaire que nous considérons est exprimé comme tu peux le voir juste ici
où gamma zéro et
gamma un sont des vecteurs unitaires représentant des états quantiques
de ce système supplémentaire.
Nous pouvons toujours écrire un état arbitraire du système combiné de cette façon.
Nous n'avons pas vraiment besoin
d'alpha et de bêta ici, mais si nous les incluons,
alors nous pouvons prendre gamma zéro et gamma un comme des vecteurs unitaires
et cela rendra la
connexion au cas plus simple que nous avons déjà considéré plus transparente.
WEBVTT
Nous pouvons effectuer une
analyse similaire à celle que nous avons déjà réalisée, mais où nous gardons aussi la trace
de ce système supplémentaire.
C'est un peu plus compliqué car nous avons le système supplémentaire, mais
l'idée est exactement la même, voici un résumé très rapide.
Voici l'état initial, voici l'état après
le gate NOT contrôlé,
et voici l'état après
l'opération Hadamard.
Si nous développons ces choses,
nous pouvons exprimer cet état comme tu peux le voir ici,
c'est l'état immédiatement
avant les mesures d'Alice, et si nous passons en revue les
possibilités comme avant
et que nous considérons ce qui
se passe quand Bob applique quelle que soit l'opération qu'il est censé appliquer,
alors nous trouvons que l'état
correct sort effectivement et le protocole fonctionne comme prévu.
Dans ce tableau d'ailleurs, nous utilisons la lettre R pour
désigner ce système supplémentaire, et tu peux voir que nous utilisons une astuce assez simple,
qui consiste à décider que nous préférons, au moins momentanément, ordonner
les systèmes comme B, R, A, Q
car c'est plus pratique pour écrire les états ici.
Selon le diagramme, les systèmes devraient être
ordonnés comme B, A, Q, R,
mais tant que nous le précisons clairement, nous pouvons choisir un ordre différent
qui est plus pratique.
En un mot, tout ce qui se passe dans cette analyse est
identique à ce qui s'est passé dans l'analyse plus simple,
mais il se trouve que nous avons
ces vecteurs supplémentaires, gamma zéro et gamma un
qui viennent essentiellement en passagers.
Nous avons toujours gamma zéro
quand il y a un facteur d'alpha et gamma un quand
il y a un facteur de bêta et en fin de compte,
tout fonctionne correctement.
Ce n'est en fait pas du tout surprenant, nous avons un processus physique qui agit comme l'opération identité sur un qubit
dans un état quantique arbitraire, et il n'y a qu'une seule
façon que cela peut se produire et c'est que l'opération
est l'opération identité.
C'est un peu plus facile à expliquer en utilisant la formulation générale
de l'information quantique, mais l'essentiel est que par linéarité,
nous n'avions pas vraiment besoin de faire cette analyse supplémentaire.
Une fois que nous savons que
la téléportation fonctionne correctement pour un qubit unique isolé, nous pouvons conclure qu'il n'y a
qu'une seule chose possible
qui peut décrire ce que fait le protocole, et c'est qu'il implémente
l'opération identité où un qubit entre ici
et sort ici, fonctionnant effectivement comme un canal quantique parfait
sans bruit.
Juste quelques remarques rapides
sur la téléportation avant de passer au
deuxième exemple de la leçon, qui est le codage superdense.
Premièrement, je pense qu'il est important de préciser que la téléportation n'est pas une application de l'information quantique, c'est un protocole
et plus précisément c'est un
protocole pour effectuer la communication quantique.
Pour que la téléportation
telle que je l'ai décrite soit utile, il doit y avoir une raison de réaliser la communication quantique.
Deuxièmement, il est raisonnable de supposer que la téléportation pourrait, un
jour, devenir un moyen standard
de communiquer de l'information quantique, et spécifiquement un processus connu sous le nom de distillation d'intrication
pourrait potentiellement être utilisé
comme moyen de communiquer des qubits de façon fiable. Si Alice et Bob savent qu'ils vont
communiquer de l'information quantique ou s'ils
ont besoin de communiquer
de l'information quantique, alors ce processus de distillation d'intrication
pourrait être utilisé pour convertir un plus grand nombre de e-bits bruités
en un plus petit nombre
de e-bits de haute qualité qui pourraient alors être utilisés pour une téléportation sans bruit ou presque sans bruit.
L'idée est que le processus
de distillation d'intrication n'est pas si délicat en un certain sens, nous pouvons accepter des pertes et
si ça ne fonctionne pas,
alors nous pourrions simplement réessayer, tandis que les qubits réels que
nous voudrions communiquer pourraient être considérés comme bien plus précieux.
Bien sûr, tout ceci n'est que spéculation, mais l'essentiel est qu'il n'est pas difficile d'imaginer des situations
dans lesquelles la téléportation
pourrait être un moyen très pratique
de communiquer des qubits.
Et le dernier point
concernant la téléportation est que l'idée derrière la téléportation et la façon dont elle fonctionne
est assez fondamentale
en information et calcul quantiques, la téléportation est vraiment une pierre angulaire de la théorie de l'information quantique et des variations
sur cette idée apparaissent souvent aussi,
c'est juste un exemple, il y a des propositions pour
implémenter différents gates quantiques
en utilisant la téléportation, mais
où différents états initiaux et mesures sont
choisis de sorte que le résultat
soit d'appliquer une opération choisie
plutôt que de communiquer.
L'exemple suivant est le codage superdense.
Comme la téléportation quantique,
le codage superdense est un protocole et ce qu'il accomplit est complémentaire à la téléportation.
Alors que la téléportation permet
à un qubit d'être transmis en utilisant un e-bit et deux
bits classiques de communication,
le codage superdense permet
à deux bits classiques d'être transmis en utilisant
un e-bit et un qubit de communication quantique.
Donc, en bref, le codage superdense permet la transmission
d'informations classiques et la raison pour laquelle on l'appelle codage superdense
WEBVTT
c'est qu'il permet à deux
bits classiques de communication d'être compressés dans un seul qubit,
mais nous devons consommer un
e-bit pour accomplir cela.
Voici une explication plus précise
de la configuration.
Encore une fois, nous avons Alice et Bob, où Alice est l'émettrice
et Bob est le récepteur, et cette fois Alice a deux bits classiques
qu'elle veut envoyer à Bob.
Alice est en mesure d'envoyer à Bob un seul qubit et Alice et Bob partagent
un e-bit qu'ils peuvent utiliser pour les aider à accomplir leur tâche,
qui est que Bob reçoive
les deux bits classiques.
Il y a un sens dans lequel cette tâche peut sembler moins intéressante que la tâche que
la téléportation accomplit,
surtout si nous considérons
que l'envoi de qubits est nettement plus
difficile ou plus compliqué que l'envoi de bits classiques,
ce qui est un point de vue assez raisonnable mais il est certainement intéressant que ce soit possible.
Une raison pour laquelle c'est intéressant
est qu'il est en fait impossible d'accomplir
cette tâche de transmettre deux bits classiques d'information
en utilisant un seul qubit sans
utiliser le e-bit.
Nous le savons grâce à un théorème célèbre connu sous le nom de théorème de Holevo.
Le théorème de Holevo est
plus général que cela, et l'énoncé précis
du théorème de Holevo est un peu technique et il
nécessite quelques explications,
mais une implication de celui-ci
est que tu ne peux pas transmettre un nombre quelconque de bits
classiques de communication en utilisant moins de qubits de
communication quantique seule.
Si tu veux transmettre de façon fiable deux bits classiques d'
information en utilisant des qubits et que tu n'as pas
de e-bit à utiliser,
tu vas devoir envoyer deux qubits, alors autant y stocker les bits que tu veux transmettre.
Une autre raison pour laquelle le codage
superdense est intéressant est à cause de la relation
complémentaire étroite qu'il a avec la téléportation, et
nous y reviendrons
un peu plus tard. Voici une description en circuit quantique du protocole de codage superdense.
Pour celui-ci, je ne vais pas
lister toutes les étapes, mais à la place nous allons juste nous en tenir à la description par diagramme de circuit.
Comme tu peux le voir, nous avons encore
Alice et Bob, où Alice est en haut
et Bob est en bas.
Voici le e-bit qui est
initialement partagé entre Alice et Bob, qui a
été établi d'une façon ou d'une autre avant l'exécution du protocole.
Alice a deux bits classiques, A et B, que tu peux voir ici
et à travers le protocole que le circuit décrit,
ces deux bits classiques
finiront entre les mains de Bob.
Il n'y a qu'un seul qubit
qui traverse la ligne entre Alice et Bob, et bien sûr il n'y a pas
de bits classiques envoyés,
c'est la transmission
des deux bits classiques qui est le but du protocole.
Tu remarqueras aussi qu'il a
exactement les mêmes composants que ceux utilisés dans la téléportation, nous avons un gate NOT
contrôlé, un gate Hadamard,
et un Z et un X-gate
contrôlés par des bits classiques.
Ils sont arrangés différemment cependant, alors passons à l'
analyse pour voir comment cela fonctionne.
Pour analyser comment fonctionne le codage superdense, commençons par écrire
la base de Bell, qui est vraiment au
cœur de l'analyse.
Ce que nous allons faire c'est
d'abord examiner l'effet que les actions d'Alice
ont sur l'état Phi plus, et ce que nous allons voir c'est
qu'Alice transforme
cet état Phi plus en l'un
des quatre états de Bell selon les bits
qu'elle veut envoyer.
Alors, écrivons un tableau pour pouvoir
suivre ce qui se passe.
Premièrement, si A et B sont tous les deux zéro, alors ni le Z-gate ni
le X-gate n'est appliqué, donc les actions d'Alice ne font rien,
ce qui veut dire que Phi
plus est transformé en Phi plus.
Nous pouvons aussi l'exprimer sous forme d'équation comme tu le vois ici,
rien n'arrive au qubit d'Alice et rien n'arrive au qubit de Bob
et ne rien faire est représenté
par la matrice identité.
Que se passe-t-il maintenant si A est égal à zéro et B est égal à un ?
Eh bien, comme B est égal à un, nous appliquons le Z-gate et
nous n'appliquons pas le X-gate car A est égal à zéro
et nous voyons que l'effet global est qu'Alice effectue un Z-gate.
Alice est à droite
car elle est en haut, bien que cela ne fasse en réalité aucune différence dans ce cas
particulier, l'effet est que
l'état Phi plus est
transformé en Phi moins, ce que tu peux voir
d'un coup d'œil dans ces expressions si tu te souviens comment fonctionne un Z-gate.
Donc, nous pouvons ajouter celui-ci à notre tableau, il y a deux autres cas à parcourir, si A est égal à un
et B est égal à zéro,
alors Alice effectue un
X-gate qui transforme Phi plus en Chi plus, et si A est égal à un
et B est égal à un,
alors Alice effectue Z, puis
X et nous obtenons Chi moins.
Ainsi, notre tableau nous dit ce qui se passe dans les quatre cas possibles, à savoir qu'Alice choisit effectivement lequel
WEBVTT
des quatre états de Bell elle
souhaite partager avec Bob, et elle a la liberté de choisir en agissant sur son qubit seul
et c'est un aspect assez intéressant
de l'intrication.
Alice envoie alors son qubit
à Bob, à ce stade, Bob tient l'un des quatre états de Bell et il a juste besoin de
déterminer lequel c'est
pour récupérer les bits.
Et nous pouvons vérifier que
bien sûr un gate NOT contrôlé suivi d'un gate Hadamard
tel que nous l'avons dans le diagramme fait la bonne chose.
Je ne vais pas les parcourir en détail, mais si tu choisis de le faire, tu trouveras que l'effet est
tel que tu le vois dans le tableau.
Une façon de vérifier
est simplement de calculer. Alternativement, nous pouvons reconnaître que nous avons en fait déjà
fait cela en sens inverse
dans la leçon précédente. Dans la leçon précédente nous avions
le gate Hadamard d'abord et le gate NOT contrôlé en deuxième
et nous avons vu que ce circuit
transformait les états de la base standard en états de Bell avec un signe moins embêtant dans l'un des cas.
Quand nous inversons l'ordre des gates et que nous considérons le fait
que ces deux gates sont leurs propres inverses,
ce que nous obtenons est l'inverse,
et donc ce que nous avons dans ce
cas c'est que l'action va dans la direction opposée
et le signe moins peut choisir de quel côté
il veut se trouver,
mais sinon, il est là où il doit être, et à ce stade il est
immédiat que la mesure révèle les valeurs correctes,
le signe moins ici ne nous dérange pas car un apparaît avec
probabilité un dans ce cas, et c'est tout ce qu'il y a à analyser.
En un mot, Alice choisit un état de Bell et Bob détermine lequel c'est.
Juste quelques brèves remarques
sur le codage superdense avant de continuer ; d'abord, nous devons reconnaître
que le codage superdense
n'est probablement pas susceptible
d'être utile ou pratique en aucun sens comme moyen de
transmettre des informations classiques.
La communication classique
est très peu coûteuse et envoyer physiquement des qubits est difficile pour le moins,
et tant que c'est le cas, nous ne nous attendrions à aucun
avantage pratique du tout à tirer du codage superdense.
Mais le fait que ce ne soit pas
susceptible d'être pratique ne signifie pas que le codage
superdense n'est pas intéressant.
C'est très intéressant en fait, d'abord, l'idée sous-jacente est
vraiment assez fondamentale,
et quand je fais référence à l'idée sous-jacente, je veux dire l'idée que si Alice
partage un état de Bell avec Bob,
alors elle peut choisir de changer cet état en n'importe quel autre état de Bell qu'elle
choisit toute seule, elle n'a pas besoin de l'aide de Bob
pour faire ça.
C'est un exemple spécifique
qui concerne les états de Bell, mais il y a une idée sous-jacente plus générale qui concerne la liberté qu'a un joueur
de transformer un état intriqué partagé avec un autre joueur, et comprendre exactement
quelle est cette liberté
est une étape importante pour comprendre l'information quantique et nous verrons exactement comment décrire cette liberté en termes simples
et élégants dans la
troisième unité de la série.
Le codage superdense fournit aussi
un exemple concret de ce que tu peux faire avec l'intrication, qui est de permettre à deux bits classiques d'être transmis
en envoyant un seul qubit. Comme je l'ai déjà mentionné, cela
est prouvablement impossible par le théorème de Holevo sans intrication.
Nous pouvons aussi considérer la téléportation et le codage superdense ensemble, et nous voyons qu'ils
établissent une équivalence
entre un qubit de communication quantique et deux bits de communication classique.
Du moment que tu es prêt à
dépenser un e-bit, tu peux effectivement
convertir l'un en l'autre.
La téléportation permet la
communication d'un qubit en utilisant deux bits classiques de communication et le codage superdense fait l'inverse
et permet deux bits classiques
de communication en utilisant un qubit de communication quantique.
Sans dépenser le e-bit, cependant, tu ne peux pas transformer
l'un en l'autre, c'est l'intrication qui
rend cela possible.
Le troisième et dernier exemple
que nous allons couvrir dans cette leçon n'est pas un protocole mais un
jeu connu sous le nom de jeu CHSH.
Quand nous parlons d'un jeu dans ce contexte, nous ne parlons pas de quelque chose censé être
joué pour le plaisir ou le sport,
mais plutôt d'une abstraction mathématique au sens de la théorie des jeux par exemple.
Les abstractions mathématiques des jeux sont très couramment étudiées en
économie et en informatique, par exemple, et il y a
beaucoup de valeur
à trouver dans l'abstraction, donc les jeux ne sont pas tous fun
dans les jeux il s'avère,
bien qu'il soit amusant d'y réfléchir.
Dans ce cas particulier, ce que nous avons c'est essentiellement
une expérience de pensée qui peut être décrite de façon
assez intuitive comme un jeu.
Les lettres CHSH font référence aux auteurs, John Clauser, Michael
Horne, Abner Shimony, et Richard Holt d'un article de 1969
où l'exemple
a été décrit pour la première fois. Ils ne l'ont pas décrit
comme un jeu d'ailleurs, et il est assez courant
de désigner cet exemple
non pas comme le jeu CHSH, mais
plutôt comme l'inégalité CHSH.
Pour un informaticien comme moi, cependant, il est tout à fait naturel
de le décrire comme un jeu.
J'ai déjà suggéré que
les abstractions mathématiques des jeux sont à la fois importantes et utiles et il existe de nombreuses catégories de jeux
WEBVTT
qui peuvent être considérées. Le jeu CHSH est un
exemple d'une classe de jeux appelés jeux non locaux.
Voici la configuration générale
pour un jeu non local.
Nous avons deux joueurs, Alice et Bob, qui coopèrent en équipe, donc ils gagnent ensemble
ou ils perdent ensemble.
Cela signifie qu'ils n'ont aucune
incitation à agir de façon égoïste, donc c'est essentiellement le contraire
des jeux à somme nulle,
qui sont purement compétitifs, ici le jeu est purement coopératif.
Il y a une troisième entité appelée l'arbitre.
L'arbitre n'est pas un joueur dans le jeu, mais c'est plutôt l'arbitre qui
gère le jeu, et en fait, tu peux considérer la spécification
d'une instance particulière
d'un jeu non local et la spécification d'un
arbitre comme étant équivalentes.
Il y a une contrainte d'importance cruciale imposée à Alice et Bob, à savoir qu'une fois le jeu commencé, il leur est interdit de
communiquer entre eux.
Ils peuvent se mettre d'accord au préalable sur
n'importe quelle stratégie qu'ils choisissent, mais aucune communication
n'est autorisée entre eux pendant le jeu lui-même.
Si tu veux, tu peux imaginer
que le jeu se déroule dans une installation sécurisée quelconque comme si l'arbitre jouait
le rôle d'un détective
et qu'Alice et Bob sont des suspects situés dans différentes
salles d'un commissariat de police, mais une autre façon de
penser à cette configuration
est qu'Alice et Bob sont
séparés par une vaste distance et la communication est interdite car la vitesse de la lumière
ne permet pas la communication
d'aller assez vite. Si Alice essaie d'envoyer un
message à Bob par exemple, le jeu sera terminé au moment
où Bob le recevra.
La façon dont fonctionne un jeu non local
est que d'abord, l'arbitre pose une question à la fois
à Alice et à Bob.
La question d'Alice est étiquetée X et la question de Bob est étiquetée Y.
En général, tu peux penser à X et Y comme étant des états classiques
parmi n'importe quels états classiques que tu veux et dans le
cas spécifique du jeu CHSH,
X et Y sont des bits.
Alice et Bob doivent ensuite fournir des réponses, la réponse d'Alice est étiquetée A,
et la réponse de Bob est étiquetée B,
et encore une fois, ces réponses peuvent être considérées comme des états classiques en général et comme les questions, elles
seront des bits dans le jeu CHSH.
À ce stade, l'
arbitre prend une décision, Alice et Bob gagnent ou perdent selon que la paire de réponses A, B
est jugée correcte pour la
paire de questions X, Y que l'arbitre a posée, et j'en dirai un peu plus
à ce sujet dans un moment.
Premièrement, regardons de plus
près l'arbitre pour comprendre ce qui est
potentiellement difficile pour Alice et Bob dans un jeu non local.
Et ce qui rend un jeu non local
potentiellement difficile c'est que l'arbitre peut utiliser l'aléatoire pour choisir les questions X et Y.
Cela signifie qu'Alice
et Bob ont une incertitude, ils ne savent pas à l'avance quelle question ils vont se faire poser, et peut-être plus important encore,
ils ne savent pas quelle question
l'autre a reçue et c'est cette incertitude
combinée au fait qu'ils ne peuvent pas communiquer
qui présente le défi.
Donc, c'est similaire à la situation où un détective
interroge deux suspects dans différentes salles, si
les suspects ne savent pas
quelles questions l'autre a reçu, c'est bien plus difficile s'ils sont coupables de garder leur version des faits cohérente.
Maintenant, j'ai mentionné il y a peu
que l'arbitre prend une décision
selon laquelle Alice et Bob ont répondu
correctement ou incorrectement
en fonction des questions
auxquelles ils ont été soumis.
On suppose que cette
décision est prise selon une règle fixe
et tu peux considérer n'importe quelle règle que tu veux,
mais quelle qu'elle soit,
on suppose qu'Alice
et Bob connaissent la règle, alors au moins ils ont une chance
de répondre correctement.
Nous allons examiner la
règle pour le jeu CHSH dans un moment, mais nous pourrions
considérer une règle différente et nous aurions un exemple différent
de jeu non local.
Certains jeux non locaux sont intéressants et en fait certains sont assez fascinants et mystérieux à ce jour et
d'autres ne sont pas si intéressants,
c'est juste la nature
du modèle de jeu non local.
Quoi qu'il en soit, ce sont les deux choses différentes qui sont nécessaires pour décrire un arbitre ; comment exactement les questions sont choisies
et quelles paires de réponses sont correctes pour chaque paire de questions possible.
Si nous avons une description
de ces deux choses, alors nous avons une description de l'arbitre et cela décrit effectivement
une instance de jeu non local.
Examinons maintenant
le jeu CHSH spécifiquement.
La façon dont le jeu est
défini ou, de façon équivalente, comment l'arbitre est défini est la suivante ;
d'abord, comme je l'ai déjà mentionné, les questions et les réponses sont toutes des bits, donc l'arbitre envoie un bit X
à Alice et un bit Y à Bob,
et ils répondent chacun avec un bit. Alice répond avec A
et Bob répond avec B.
La façon dont l'arbitre choisit
quelles questions poser est simple, il les choisit
de façon aléatoire uniformément,
donc, la paire de questions X, Y est également susceptible d'être n'importe
laquelle des quatre possibilités, zéro, zéro, zéro, un,
un, zéro, et un, un.
Enfin, la règle qui
détermine quelles réponses gagnent et quelles réponses perdent est
que la paire de réponses A, B est correcte pour la paire de questions X, Y
WEBVTT
si et seulement si le ou exclusif de A et B est égal au et logique de X et Y.
Cela peut être un peu plus facile à assimiler si nous exprimons ces conditions
sous la forme d'un tableau comme tu le vois ici.
Dans la première colonne, nous avons les quatre paires de questions possibles, et dans la deuxième colonne nous
avons les conditions sur A et B
qui sont requises pour
qu'Alice et Bob gagnent.
Dans les trois premiers cas,
le et de A et Y est zéro, donc le ou exclusif doit être égal à zéro
pour qu'ils gagnent,
et c'est la même chose que de dire que A et B doivent être égaux car A et B sont des bits,
et dans le quatrième cas,
le et de X et Y est égal
à un et donc le ou exclusif de A et B doit être égal à un pour qu'Alice et Bob gagnent
et c'est la même chose
que de dire que A et B doivent être différents.
Alors, c'est le jeu CHSH, et maintenant nous pouvons réfléchir à
différentes stratégies possibles pour Alice et Bob et à leur
efficacité dans ce jeu.
Commençons par réfléchir aux
stratégies déterministes où la réponse d'Alice A est une
fonction de la question X qu'elle reçoit, et
de même, la réponse de Bob B
est une fonction de la
question Y qu'il reçoit.
Et il s'avère qu'aucune
stratégie déterministe ne peut gagner à chaque fois.
Une façon de le raisonner est
simplement de passer une par une à travers toutes les stratégies
déterministes possibles et de vérifier que chacune d'elles perd
pour au moins une des quatre
paires de questions possibles.
Alice et Bob ont chacun
quatre fonctions possibles parmi lesquelles choisir, nous avons vu ces
quatre fonctions dans la leçon un, donc il y a 16 possibilités
à vérifier en tout.
Une autre façon de le voir est de
réfléchir aux équations ici à l'écran, nous pensons
à des stratégies déterministes
où A et B sont des fonctions
de X et Y respectivement.
Donc par exemple, A de zéro
représente la réponse d'Alice quand sa question X est égale à zéro et A de un représente la réponse d'Alice
quand sa question X est égale à un.
Ce sont les quatre équations
qui doivent être vraies pour que les conditions de victoire
soient remplies dans chacun des quatre cas.
Par exemple, si X est égal à
zéro et Y est égal à zéro, alors le ou exclusif de A
et B doit être égal à zéro,
tandis que dans le cas où X est égal à un et Y est égal à un, le
ou exclusif de A et B doit être égal à un.
Une façon de voir qu'il n'est
pas possible de choisir les fonctions A et B de sorte que
ces équations soient toutes vraies, est simplement de prendre le ou exclusif
de toutes les équations.
Le ou exclusif de n'importe quelle
valeur binaire avec elle-même est égal à zéro, et donc il s'ensuit que le ou exclusif
des membres de gauche
est égal à zéro, c'est
parce que nous avons deux instances de a zéro, deux instances de a un,
deux instances de b zéro
et deux instances de b un.
Donc, les xorer tous ensemble
nous donne la réponse finale de zéro, mais si nous prenons le ou exclusif des membres de droite des équations,
nous obtenons un et non zéro. Donc les quatre équations
ne peuvent pas toutes être vraies, au moins l'une d'elles doit être fausse
et cela entraînera une
perte pour Alice et Bob dans au moins l'un des quatre cas.
Et donc il s'ensuit car l'arbitre choisit les questions
uniformément que la probabilité pour Alice et Bob de gagner
en utilisant une stratégie déterministe
est d'au plus trois quarts ou 75%.
Le fait qu'Alice et Bob peuvent gagner avec probabilité trois quarts est assez facile à voir
en réalité, si Alice et Bob répondent tous les deux zéro tout
le temps, par exemple,
ils auront raison trois
fois sur quatre.
Donc Alice et Bob ne peuvent pas
faire mieux que gagner 75% du temps en utilisant une
stratégie déterministe.
Mais qu'en est-il d'une stratégie probabiliste ?
Eh bien, il s'avère qu'utiliser
une stratégie probabiliste ne peut pas les aider du tout, c'est parce que chaque
stratégie probabiliste
peut alternativement être considérée
comme une sélection aléatoire d'une stratégie déterministe tout comme les opérations probabilistes peuvent être considérées
comme des sélections aléatoires d'
opérations déterministes, comme nous l'avons vu dans la première leçon.
La moyenne n'est jamais
plus grande que le maximum, donc il s'ensuit qu'une
stratégie probabiliste n'offre aucun avantage
en termes de victoire
par rapport à une stratégie déterministe. Cela inclut même la possibilité que les choix aléatoires d'Alice et Bob soient corrélés.
Donc, en résumé, gagner avec probabilité trois quarts est le mieux qu'Alice
et Bob puissent faire en utilisant n'importe quelle stratégie classique,
qu'elle soit déterministe
ou probabiliste.
La question naturelle à se poser à ce stade est de savoir si Alice et Bob peuvent faire mieux en utilisant une stratégie quantique,
et en particulier
s'ils partagent un état quantique intriqué qu'ils auraient pu préparer
avant de jouer au jeu, est-ce que cela peut les aider ?
La réponse est oui, ça le peut, et c'est le but de l'exemple et c'est pourquoi c'est si intéressant.
Alors voyons exactement comment
Alice et Bob peuvent faire mieux dans ce jeu en utilisant l'intrication.
WEBVTT
La première chose que nous devons faire est de définir un vecteur d'état quantique Chi
thêta pour chaque angle thêta, comme tu peux le voir ici à l'écran.
Donc, Chi thêta est égal à
cosinus thêta fois ket zéro plus sinus thêta fois ket
un, et ici d'ailleurs,
nous pensons aux
angles en termes de radians.
Donc par exemple, voici le vecteur que nous obtenons quand thêta est égal à pi sur
quatre, soit 45 degrés.
Le cosinus de pi sur quatre
et le sinus de pi sur quatre sont tous les deux égaux à un sur
la racine carrée de deux, donc c'est juste un autre
nom pour l'état plus.
Voici un autre exemple quand thêta est égal à trois fois pi sur huit, et au cas où tu ne
connaîtrais pas le sinus
et le cosinus de trois fois pi sur huit par cœur,
voici un tableau des sinus et des cosinus dont nous
allons avoir besoin
tout au long de cet exemple
et qui comprend ceux dont nous avons besoin pour ce vecteur particulier.
Maintenant, si nous voulons calculer le produit scalaire entre deux quelconques de ces vecteurs
pour des angles, alpha et bêta disons, c'est
simple à faire.
Nous n'avons que des
entrées de nombres réels dans ces vecteurs donc il n'y a pas
de conjugués complexes dont s'occuper et nous obtenons le produit des cosinus
plus le produit des sinus, et nous pouvons utiliser l'une des
formules dites d'addition d'angles
pour simplifier cela, c'est le
cosinus de la différence entre les angles et
parce que la fonction cosinus
est symétrique autour de zéro,
l'ordre dans lequel nous les prenons n'a en fait pas d'importance.
Si tu n'as pas ce genre
d'identités trigonométriques mémorisées,
d'ailleurs, tu n'es pas seul, mais tu n'as pas à t'en souvenir,
tu peux juste les rechercher. Celle-ci a du sens
cependant quand tu penses à l'interprétation géométrique
du produit scalaire
entre des vecteurs unitaires réels comme le cosinus de l'angle entre eux.
Si nous calculons le produit scalaire
du produit tensoriel de deux quelconques de ces vecteurs
avec l'état Phi plus, nous obtenons une expression similaire
sauf qu'il y a une racine
carrée de deux au dénominateur.
C'est la première fois
que l'état Phi plus apparaît dans le contexte
de cet exemple d'ailleurs, et nous verrons exactement pourquoi nous nous intéressons
à ce produit scalaire particulier sous peu, mais pour l'instant
observons simplement que nous obtenons la même expression que nous avions
pour le produit scalaire divisé
par la racine carrée de deux et donc nous pouvons simplifier comme avant.
Ensuite, nous allons définir une
matrice unitaire, U thêta, pour chaque angle thêta
comme tu le vois ici,
il n'est pas difficile de
vérifier que c'est bien une matrice unitaire.
La chose clé que nous devons
reconnaître est que le vecteur si thêta est orthogonal au
vecteur si thêta plus pi sur deux, et cela fait sens
parce que si nous faisons tourner de pi sur deux, soit 90 degrés, nous
obtenons un vecteur orthogonal.
Si nous multiplions ensuite U
thêta par U thêta dagger, nous obtenons la matrice identité.
Intuitivement parlant,
ce que cette matrice fait en tant qu'opération est de
transformer si thêta en ket zéro et si thêta plus pi deux en ket un.
À ce stade, nous avons
tout ce dont nous avons besoin pour décrire la stratégie d'Alice et Bob.
Premièrement, tout comme nous avions pour la téléportation et le codage superdense, Alice et Bob vont commencer en partageant un e-bit.
Alice tient un qubit A,
Bob tient un qubit B, et ensemble les deux qubits
sont dans l'état Phi plus.
Les actions d'Alice sont les suivantes : elle regarde le bit X qu'elle
reçoit de l'arbitre,
et si X est égal à zéro,
elle effectue U zéro sur A, ce qui est la même chose
que ne rien faire car U zéro est la matrice identité,
si X est égal à un en revanche, elle applique U pi sur quatre à A.
Après avoir appliqué l'une
des deux opérations, elle mesure A en utilisant une
mesure en base standard et envoie n'importe quel résultat
qu'elle obtient à l'arbitre.
Bob fait quelque chose de très similaire, son qubit s'appelle B bien sûr, et il reçoit Y de l'
arbitre et non X
mais la différence clé est
qu'il utilise des angles différents pour ses opérations unitaires.
Si Y est égal à zéro, il
applique U pi sur huit, et si Y est égal à un, il applique U moins pi sur huit.
Et nous verrons pourquoi ces choix d'angles sont de bons choix sous peu,
ce n'est pas du tout évident.
Et voici un diagramme de circuit
qui exprime cette stratégie.
Bob est en haut et Alice
est en bas cette fois, voici le e-bit qui arrive
et ce sont les gates unitaires
qu'Alice et Bob pourraient ou ne pourraient pas appliquer
selon ce que sont X et Y.
Pour celui-ci et celui-ci, nous avons des gates qui sont contrôlés soit par le bit X soit par le bit Y
et pour ces deux-là ici, nous avons ce qui ressemble
à des gates de contrôle sauf que le cercle n'est pas rempli.
Et ce que cela signifie c'est
que si le bit de contrôle est à zéro, alors le gate est effectué et si le contrôle est à
un, alors rien ne se passe.
Donc, c'est juste comme un
gate de contrôle ordinaire sauf que les rôles de zéro et un pour le contrôle sont échangés.
Donc, effectivement, Bob
effectue ce gate ici si Y est égal à zéro, il
effectue ce gate ici
WEBVTT
si Y est égal à un, et de même, Alice effectue ce gate ici
si X est égal à zéro, et ce gate ici,
si X est égal à un.
Voilà donc la stratégie d'Alice et Bob et maintenant il nous faut juste
déterminer à quel point elle fonctionne bien.
Pour l'analyse de la stratégie quantique que je viens de décrire, nous
n'avons vraiment besoin que de deux choses à ce stade, premièrement, la
matrice unitaire U Thêta
est telle que tu la vois ici, et
deuxièmement nous avons cette formule.
Nous n'avons en fait même plus besoin de la définition du vecteur si thêta, ces deux équations sont tout ce dont nous avons besoin.
Il y a quatre cas à
considérer en commençant par le cas un, qui est que X égal
zéro et Y égal zéro.
Et si nous regardons la stratégie, nous allons trouver que dans ce
cas Alice effectue U zéro sur son qubit et Bob effectue
U pi sur huit sur son qubit.
Rappelle-toi, Alice est en
bas et Bob est en haut, donc l'état qu'ils
obtiennent ressemble à ceci.
Et en développant cela
selon la définition de U thêta, nous obtenons cette
expression que tu vois ici.
Nous n'avons pas besoin de développer
cela davantage car nous avons l'autre
formule pour nous aider.
Et si nous appliquons cette formule
pour chacun des quatre termes, ce que nous obtenons est ceci.
À ce stade Alice et Bob mesurent tous les deux et voici un tableau qui
explique la distribution des résultats.
Nous prenons la valeur absolue
au carré des coefficients pour obtenir les probabilités, ce qui se trouve être les
carrés des coefficients
car les coefficients sont
tous des nombres réels dans ce cas.
Si nous utilisons les
valeurs de sinus et cosinus du début de la leçon
avec quelques symétries, nous pouvons exprimer ces probabilités
telles que nous les avons ici
dans la dernière colonne.
Maintenant, ce qui nous intéresse vraiment
c'est la probabilité qu'ils gagnent, et rappelle-toi que, dans le cas où X et Y sont tous les deux zéro,
ils gagnent si A et B sont égaux et ils perdent si A et B ne sont pas égaux.
Si nous calculons ces probabilités, nous trouvons que la probabilité
que A et B soient égaux est la somme de ce nombre et de ce nombre,
ce qui est égal à deux plus
racine de deux le tout divisé par quatre, soit environ 85%.
La probabilité que A et B ne soient pas égaux est deux moins racine de deux le tout divisé par quatre, ce qui est naturellement un moins la quantité
que nous venons de calculer, donc
ils gagnent avec une probabilité d'environ 85% dans ce cas.
Il y a trois autres cas à considérer, mais ils sont tous très similaires à celui-ci,
dans le cas où X égale
zéro et Y égale un, Bob applique U moins pi sur huit plutôt que U pi sur huit,
les valeurs dans les
formules changent quelque peu, mais nous nous retrouvons avec exactement
les mêmes probabilités que dans le cas précédent.
Quand X égale zéro et Y égale un, Alice et Bob gagnent encore
quand A et B sont égaux et donc nous avons exactement la
même probabilité de victoire
qu'avant.
Dans le troisième cas, quand X est égal à un et Y est égal à zéro, nous
avons une situation similaire, les angles sont différents,
mais ils ont exactement
la même relation les uns
avec les autres, et en fait, nous obtenons exactement le
même vecteur que dans le cas précédent.
Donc les probabilités sont les mêmes et la probabilité de victoire aussi.
Le dernier cas est un peu
différent comme on pourrait s'y attendre car la condition de victoire
est différente dans ce cas.
Quand X et Y sont tous les deux égaux à un, Alice et Bob gagnent quand
A et B sont différents.
La méthode de base est la même, bien que les angles soient différents, cette fois, nous obtenons ce vecteur ici
et tu peux le vérifier en effectuant les soustractions requises.
Les probabilités changent finalement, et si nous regardons les valeurs dont nous avons besoin, nous voyons que les probabilités ont effectivement
échangé leurs positions par rapport à avant, donc cette fois c'est la probabilité
que A ne soit pas égal à B qui est la plus grande des deux,
mais c'est ce que nous voulons car dans ce cas, Alice et Bob gagnent quand
A et B ne sont pas égaux.
Donc encore une fois, ils gagnent avec
une probabilité d'environ 85%.
Étant donné qu'ils gagnent dans chaque
cas avec la même probabilité, qui est deux plus racine de deux
le tout divisé par quatre ou environ 85%,
c'est la probabilité
qu'ils gagnent dans l'ensemble.
C'est mieux que ce que peut faire n'importe quelle stratégie classique pour ce jeu, et c'est
ce qui le rend intéressant.
Il se trouve que c'est la
probabilité de victoire optimale pour n'importe quelle stratégie quantique, tu
ne peux pas faire mieux que ça en utilisant n'importe quel état intriqué.
Ce fait est connu sous le nom d'inégalité de Tsirelson, elle est nommée d'après Boris
Tsirelson qui l'a prouvée en premier, et à ma connaissance c'était
l'un des premiers
à décrire cet exemple comme un jeu. Au cas où l'analyse
que nous venons de parcourir semblerait un peu mystérieuse,
il est possible d'y réfléchir
géométriquement, ce qui pourrait être utile pour
te donner une meilleure intuition du choix des angles.
Spécifiquement, si nous utilisons la
formule que tu vois ici, que nous pouvons facilement déduire
des expressions
que nous avons déjà trouvées pour les
produits scalaires impliqués, alors nous pouvons alternativement
exprimer les probabilités des différents résultats de mesure possibles
WEBVTT
dans les quatre cas comme suit ; d'abord, si X, Y égale zéro, zéro, alors ce sont les probabilités
des différents résultats de mesure, et tu dois soit te souvenir soit revenir à l'analyse
que nous venons de parcourir pour conclure en utilisant notre formule.
Ici, nous pouvons voir les
différents vecteurs d'état dessinés comme avant, et le code couleur ici
est que le bleu correspond
au résultat zéro et le rouge
correspond au résultat un.
Tu peux voir que l'angle
entre les vecteurs bleus et l'angle entre les vecteurs rouges
est relativement petit,
c'est pi sur huit dans les deux cas, donc le cosinus est relativement grand, et cela signifie que la
probabilité que les deux résultats
soient égaux est relativement grande.
Dans le cas où X, Y égale zéro, un, c'est une situation similaire, les
angles entre les vecteurs de même couleur sont petits,
donc la probabilité de
résultats égaux est encore relativement grande.
Le troisième cas est similaire, et dans le quatrième cas
quand X, Y égale un, un, quelque chose d'intéressant se produit,
cette fois, juste en raison de la façon dont,
ces vecteurs ont été choisis, nous voyons que les angles entre
les vecteurs de même couleur
sont relativement grands, et spécifiquement les angles sont trois fois
pi sur huit dans les deux cas.
Cela signifie que la probabilité
que les résultats de mesure soient égaux est relativement petite, mais c'est l'unique cas
dans lequel Alice et Bob gagnent
quand leurs réponses divergent,
donc c'est ce que nous voulons.
Encore une fois, voici les vecteurs : quand X, Y égale zéro, zéro,
quand X, Y égale zéro, un,
quand X, Y égale un, zéro,
et quand X, Y égale un, un.
Et peut-être que cette image géométrique
est utile pour construire une certaine intuition
sur la façon dont cette stratégie fonctionne
et pourquoi ces différents angles ont été choisis comme ils l'ont été.
Pour conclure la leçon, je vais faire quelques brèves
remarques sur le jeu CHSH.
Premièrement, comme je l'ai déjà mentionné, cet exemple n'est pas toujours
décrit comme un jeu.
Dans la communauté physique, par exemple, il est plus courant que
l'exemple soit décrit simplement comme une expérience plutôt que comme un jeu
et Alice et Bob sont
considérés comme des détecteurs plutôt que comme des joueurs.
L'idée de base d'une expérience comme celle-ci où l'intrication conduit
à des résultats statistiques qui sont incompatibles avec
toute description classique
ou plus généralement toute
théorie basée sur des soi-disant variables cachées locales,
est due à John Bell, le homonyme des états de Bell,
et donc les gens font souvent référence
aux expériences de ce type comme des tests de Bell.
Les gens font aussi parfois
référence au théorème de Bell, qui peut être formulé de différentes façons, mais il dit essentiellement
que la mécanique quantique
n'est pas compatible avec les soi-disant théories de variables cachées locales.
Le jeu ou l'inégalité CHSH est essentiellement un exemple très beau et propre d'un test de Bell,
et tu peux considérer
cet exemple comme une preuve ou une démonstration du théorème de Bell.
La deuxième remarque est que le jeu CHSH nous offre une façon de tester expérimentalement que la théorie de l'information quantique
est une théorie précise. Nous pouvons effectivement mettre en place des expériences qui implémentent le jeu CHSH,
y compris le genre de
stratégie basée sur l'intrication que je viens de décrire, et
voir si ça fonctionne, et ça fonctionne.
Cela nous donne un
haut degré de confiance dans le fait que l'intrication est réelle, et contrairement aux façons peut-être
vagues ou poétiques
que nous essayons de trouver
pour expliquer l'intrication, le jeu ou l'expérience CHSH
nous donne une façon concrète
et testable d'observer l'intrication.
Si ça semble important,
c'est parce que ça l'est, et le Prix Nobel de physique 2022
reconnaît exactement cela.
Le prix a été décerné à
Alain Aspect, John Clauser, qui est le C dans CHSH, et Anton Zeilinger
pour des expériences avec des photons intriqués qui ont établi la violation
des inégalités de Bell, ou en d'autres termes, qui ont
montré que les stratégies quantiques
du type que j'ai décrit fonctionnent réellement et surpassent les stratégies classiques.
Et si tu es intéressé à
en apprendre davantage sur ce sujet, je t'encourage à regarder
la vidéo sur le Théorème de Bell par ma collègue Olivia Lanes,
ici même sur la chaîne YouTube Qiskit.
Et pour finir, le sujet des
jeux non locaux de façon plus générale est vraiment fascinant, et c'est
un domaine de recherche actif
qui rassemble
la physique, l'informatique et les mathématiques pures et il y a encore de nombreuses
questions intéressantes
sur les jeux non locaux qui
restent sans réponse à ce jour.
Et voilà la fin de la leçon quatre, ainsi que la fin de
l'unité un de la série sur les Bases de l'Information Quantique.
La première leçon expliquait
comment l'information quantique fonctionne pour les systèmes simples isolés, et la deuxième leçon expliquait
comment l'information quantique
fonctionne pour les systèmes multiples,
ce qui émerge assez naturellement de la façon dont elle fonctionne pour les systèmes simples.
WEBVTT
La troisième leçon a introduit
le modèle de circuit quantique de calcul, et dans la quatrième leçon, nous avons examiné trois exemples importants
qui illustrent des choses que
nous pouvons faire avec l'intrication.
En chemin, nous avons vu des concepts mathématiques très importants,
notamment les produits tensoriels et les produits scalaires, et nous avons observé
certaines limitations fondamentales
de l'information quantique.
J'espère que tu te joindras à moi pour
la prochaine unité de la série, qui portera sur les algorithmes quantiques, où nous nous concentrerons sur la question
des avantages computationnels que
l'information quantique offre.
Au revoir jusqu'à la prochaine fois.